JEFF JOHNSON: Hi developers.
My name is Jeff, and I'm a
software engineer working
on Open Source at Google.
ALPHA CHEN: I'm Alpha, and I'm
a lab developer at Pivotal.
JEFF JOHNSON: I hope
your Cloud Foundry
Series is going great so far.
You and I are going to spend
the next few episodes talking
about Cloud Foundry
and Stackdriver.
Stackdriver is Google's
suite of logging, monitoring,
and developer tools.
I'm going to be
joined by experts
who know way more than
I do about Cloud Foundry
and Stackdriver.
So Alpha, can you give us a
little background about how
Cloud Foundry is deployed?
ALPHA CHEN: Sure thing, Jeff.
Cloud Foundry is made
up of many services that
run on an on-prem
data center, or the VM
infrastructure of a cloud host,
such as Google Cloud Platform.
These services are deployed as
jobs by BOSH to several VMS,
and together they form
a working Cloud Foundry.
JEFF JOHNSON: So we've got
all these applications that
must be doing tons of logging,
in addition to Linux services,
logging to sys log.
How can an operator
make sense of all that?
ALPHA CHEN: That's
a great question.
Every BOSH job writes logs to a
known location on the instance.
So an operator can
use the BOSH CLI
to grab a recent set of logs
or stream them as they come in.
This is fantastic
for initial setup,
but operators really need
to set up a long term
solution for monitoring
and storing logs.
JEFF JOHNSON: That's why we
work together with Pivotal
to develop these Stackdriver
tools BOSH release.
This drop-in solution
gives operators
long term access to this
information in Stackdriver
logging and monitoring.
ALPHA CHEN: We work
together in Seattle
using a Pivotal process.
We co-located once a
week in our office,
and once a week in yours.
And together we developed the
Stackdriver [INAUDIBLE] tooling
that enables Cloud Foundry
to talk to Stackdriver.
JEFF JOHNSON: We did
this all out in the open
and it was a lot more fun than
I thought it was going to be.
Now hear me out.
We had a lot of folks
who knew about BOSH,
a couple of folks who knew
about Cloud Foundry and Go,
a little bit of GCP of course,
but not a lot of overlap.
By pair programming we were
able to spread that knowledge
across, and we all came out
with a much better understanding
of each other's products.
So Alpha, can you pair
with me and show me
how to set up Stackdriver
tools on Cloud Foundry?
ALPHA CHEN: Let's get to.
It First, let's upload this
Stackdriver tools release
to our BOSH director
from our open source
project hosted on GitHub.
Now we'll have to modify our
deployment manifest to include
the release.
The two jobs,
Google [? Phone D ?]
and Stackdriver
agent will need to be
collocated on the instances
that you want monitored.
After that we'll have to
run BOSH deploy as usual.
In recent versions
of BOSH we should
be able to deploy
this as an add-on.
JEFF JOHNSON: Wow.
That's the fastest BOSH
deploy that's ever happened.
Editing is a real miracle.
It might take a few
minutes on your machine.
So now that we've got jobs
running across our Cloud
Foundry, which means our host
logs and metrics should appear
in Stackdriver,
let's make our data
little more interesting
by waiting a week or so.
ALPHA CHEN: Wow,
that went by fast.
JEFF JOHNSON: Great.
Let's dive in.
ALPHA CHEN: As the
logs stream in,
we can view and drill
down the specific events.
These logs include all
distance log output
from the instances
in our deployment,
as well as the logs
from any other BOSH jobs
on the instance.
Each entry contains contacts,
including the job name,
which allows operators to easily
filter and search through logs.
All of these logs come from
the Google Fluent E job
that we deployed earlier.
JEFF JOHNSON: As for
the Stackdriver agent,
that's responsible for gathering
host metrics with Collect D
and sending them back to
Stackdriver monitoring.
I'm going to hop into
Stackdriver monitoring,
and we can now see detailed
information about our Cloud
Foundry infrastructure.
Let's take a look at the
dashboard I created earlier.
The dashboard shows metrics
gathered by the agent.
Now we can look
for abnormalities
and set up a learning threshold,
such as high memory usage.
ALPHA CHEN: This
is a great start
to having a single pane of
glass for a CF operator.
These deployments are made up
of tons of virtual machines.
So having a heartbeat
like this is a great thing
to keep an eye on.
JEFF JOHNSON: Let's look at
the log metrics we've created.
This metric is based off
of an event appearing
in the Stackdriver logs.
We can drill into the actual
log events where this occurred.
This gives us a query in
the Stackdriver logging
console specific to our
event and time range.
I'm going to filter to our
specific virtual machine
and remove the event filter
to gain some context.
This is an incredibly
useful tool
for keeping an eye
on your entire system
and drilling down when
something pops up.
That's host monitoring
with Stackdriver.
ALPHA CHEN: And check
out the description
for more resources
on integrating
Cloud Foundry with Stackdriver.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF JOHNSON: Thank
you all for watching.
Check out some more videos
we've done about Stackdriver
and Cloud Foundry, and
check out our play list
for even more information.
Make sure to subscribe to
the Google Cloud channel
right here.